(upbeat music)
- I have no idea.
(laughs)
- That's the name of them or
you just mean in general, furry animals?
- They (bleep) with tails
on and (bleep). (laughs)
- Furry, nothing.
- I don't know man.
They dress up like Star Fox
and they (bleep) each other.
Is there a furry behind me? (laughs)
- [Haven] Hi. (Marcus laughing)
Hi.
- Hi! (chuckles)
(laughing)
- Oh hi!
- Hi.
- Oh my gosh.
You guys are,
wait.
- And now I feel bad
for laughing in person.
This is much different.
- My name is Lumio
Draco, that is my furname
and I am a celestial moon dragon.
- My fursona is Haven Fusky.
I've been in the furry community
slash fandom for four years now.
- I have been in the fandom for,
I wanna say goin' on seven years now.
- I've never had one
of those moments where,
oh, are they right behind me?
But as soon as I started
makin' jokes about furries
I heard the rattlin' and
I'm assumin' y'all don't
commit a lot of crime
'cause you can't sneak up on anybody.
- You can't.
- (laughs) No.
- I'm assuming you're
docile people. (laughs)
- [Lumio] The furry
community is essentially
enthusiasts of anthropomorphic animals,
which means animals with
humanlike characteristics.
- But I've had so many questions
and now I'm just frozen,
mostly 'cause y'all still
look like y'all could hurt me
(Haven chuckles) if y'all felt like it.
- You don't have any fur.
- I don't.
- He's a scaly.
- [Lumio] I am what
you would call a scaly.
- A scaly?
- Yes.
- How you're dressed, is
that how you see yourself?
- [Haven] Yeah, it's called a fursona.
- Where do you usually go in character?
- [Lumio] Wherever there's an opportunity.
- [Haven] Yeah, yeah. (Lumio laughs)
- [Lumio] But commonly the furry community
has their own furry
conventions that they go to.
- [Haven] Other than conventions,
I go out to clubs like this and
then also I've done
charity, I've done parades.
We'll go to children's hospitals
to kinda brighten up their day.
- [Lumio] We actually have
a group that's devoted to
doin' that on a weekly basis,
to cheer up the children.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- Oh that's incredible.
- I have to ask, how white is...
- How white is furry?
- Yeah.
- [Lumio] I don't know the
statistics but yeah, it...
- [Haven] Just blunlty
speaking, it's pretty light.
There's a group that just started doing
POC focused room parties.
- Yeah?
- [Haven] And I'm like
yes, that's awesome!
That's amazing!
It's very open across
the spectrum of LGBT.
- Oh yeah.
One of the biggest
diversities in our fandom is,
we come from a wide spectrum
of sexual orientation,
gender identity and gender expression.
- I've been an out and
open gay man for many years
and what I've found with the community,
because we sort of exist
as these characters,
we are much more likely to open up.
- A lot of people who
enter in to this community,
they're very pressured to
be someone that they're not.
By creating a fursona you can alter that
and have the ability to
really discover who you are
from a third person perspective.
- Do you only do relationships
with other furries
or do you have like a furry relationship
versus human relationship?
- [Haven] You know, I'm one of those,
I would be open either
way as long as I feel
that we're gonna get along in general
then you know, it doesn't matter.
And if they can deal with
this every now and then.
- So, I've seen some furry porn, I guess.
- [Haven] Uh-huh.
- You know they have the ears
and they have the bunny tail.
- [Lumio] Mm-hm. (chuckling)
- And that's usually as far as I've seen.
I haven't seen two people in costumes.
Is that a, like?
- [Haven] Okay, so because
we're adults here, you know,
you have to say it's
something that does happen
but it's not as often as people think.
- As people think?
- There are people that enjoy the
adult aspects of it and
I think that's okay,
but it's not the sort
of levels of debauchery
that, you know, people think it may be.
- I would say the main misconceptions
would be that it's a fetish.
It is not.
It's an interest.
It can be a lifestyle.
It can be whatever you want it to be.
For me personally it's about
self exploration and self expression.
- People think that we're
the worst of the worst.
That we don't have anywhere else to go
and so we sort of fall into the fandom.
But it's entirely untrue.
I think we're some of the best
of what we have to offer society,
as people and as our characters.
Before you get to know
us, we may come across
as kinda weird or what have you.
But we come from all walks
of life, all professions.
I mean, we have doctors and lawyers
and engineers and
psychiatrists, psychologists.
- [Lumio] And a famous one
is a chemist, Dr. Uncle Kage.
- You got people who are like,
secretly Will Smith's Scientologist?
Are there any people
that y'all low key know
as a furry but like, that Emma Stone,
actually a furry but people don't know?
- Yep.
- Oh, so actual celebrities?
- Yep, celebrities, oh yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- I don't want you to out
'em as like, a big deal,
but there are people
you know, like low key.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
- That's (bleep) up.
That is so dope!
- [Lumio] Furries who are in
suit is like 15% of the fandom.
You look around in your own social circle,
you probably have someone
who is a furry themselves.
- I think I'm like, half way
on my way to being a furry.
- Oh you're, yeah.
- You should create a fursona.
- I should.
- [Haven] If you were to wake
up tomorrow as an animal,
what would that animal be.
- Goddammit, see...
Bears swim good.
It'd have to be some
kinda bear with flight.
- Right now I'm really into elephants
which would work perfectly
for my size at this time.
(laughing)
- Some kind of flighted bear that I can...
- Yeah.
- Swoop in and grab salmon.
- I kind of like, relate,
and this is weird maybe, but to a phoenix
'cause I've been through a lot and then
I've still managed to pull myself up.
- Or I could do a
beautiful, colorful sloth.
- [Haven] Absolutely, yeah.
- [Joanie] That sleeps a lot.
- I don't know what to call it though.
- [Haven] Yeah, you need a name.
- [Lumio] Well that's
the next question is,
you know, what'll be the name?
- I want it to have Ss so
it'll all flow like sloth.
- [Haven] Like sloth?
- Do people do regular names?
- Yeah.
- Some do, some...
- Is there like a giraffe
named Darius somewhere?
- [Haven] (chuckling) Yes.
I keep coming up with silly
Buffy sort of names like...
- Like what?
- Like Buffy. (laughs)
I kinda like Sasha.
- (gasps) I like that!
- Sasha.
- [Haven] Sasha Sloth.
- I like that.
- [Haven] I'm going like,
Xander, but trying to...
- Feminize it?
- Yeah.
- Like Xandie?
- Xandie!
- Yeah, Xandie.
- I like that.
- Xandie the phoenix.
- I can't think of a name.
I feel so bad on the spot.
- [Haven] Okay, so
let's use the drag name.
The name of the first
street that you grew up on
and first pet's name.
- That's it.
- Melrose Polly?
- Hey! (laughs)
- Boom.
- Melrose Polly.
- There we go.
- The flyin' bear squirrel. (laughs)
- What the community means to
me is that sense of family.
Sometimes we come from
families that can be
very abusive to us, so it's
nice to have a family that
really does care about us and
really allows us to be who we want to be.
- No, they were super sweet.
I figured they'd be sweet.
- It's actually really unfortunate that
they have such a negative
stereotype against them
because they're just wonderful
people who wanna go out,
escape, and make everyone else happy
and that's a wonderful thing.
- I just think people who
don't think it's a good idea
probably have a hard time
being their authentic self.
Because if you can be
who you are and have fun
life is a lot more enjoyable.
- What you feel that
you're missing in your life
you probably can and will find that
within this particular fandom
and within this community.
- Just, don't judge anybody,
even if they're dressed up
like an animal that doesn't exist
'cause they're probably nice
and it's not all about (bleep).
Is there like a higher,
is there like, a grand wizard? (laughs)
- [Haven] A grand wizard? (laughing)
- Hey, unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- Subscribe here.
- That was my part.